family were relaxing in their Garden on
Saturday night in the small Hamlet San
Ebola in Brittany they were having a
barbecue when a gunman appeared and
started firing at them their eldest
daughter Salem Thornton was killed both
parents were injured and it is
understood the father Adrian is in a
critical condition fighting for his life
their youngest daughter Celeste survived
she had to raise the alarm running to
neighbors to tell them her sister was
dead the suspect is their neighbor a 71
year old Dutchman named Dirk Ross local
authorities say there was a long-winning
dispute between the two households about
noise and a hedge between the two
properties he was found to have alcohol
and cannabis in his system we have
spoken to someone who works at the
school Salon attended she said the
family had just got their passports
through to travel to the UK in a couple
of weeks to see relatives she said they
haven't been to the UK to see their
family since before covert I also spoke
to a friend of Silence who told me she
was a very very sweet girl